[Music]
I remember when the first search engines
came around and big back then Alta Vista
was a very big thing Alta Vista tried to
strike a balance between the
inconveniences in terms of advertising
and so on it could put on the user and
the utility it had for the user so it
would for instance mix search results
with advertising and at this point
Google came along Google was very small
and inconsequential and nobody really
took it seriously but it did an amazing
thing it did give people exactly what
they wanted it gives them a pretty much
at free experience and gave them exactly
the search results that they wanted the
best ones closest ones to what people
wanted to have and Google dramatically
outperformed Alta Vista Alta Vista
disappeared and that was an amazing
insight to see that if you are in a
dramatically scalable economy like the
internet where you have the biggest
amount of competition that you can
possibly have you need to build a
product that is optimally aligned with
the interest of the users unless you
manage to get some kind of monopoly and
can drive out other competition and so
when we build new products in that space
we have to think about how to build the
most useful product not necessarily just
the product that is going to make the
biggest amount of money that is going to
have the most efficient business model
in some sense or the best business case
eventually it's going to be the product
that is getting the most used by people
and people will find out that they will
use most what is most useful to them
in the long run that's going to be the
stuff that is not addictive that is
hygienic that serves their actual needs
that makes them more happy and fulfilled
and right now be mostly build
applications that utilize the cravings
of people that make them addicted people
start checking the smartphones every few
seconds to see if a new email arrived
but this new email is not going to make
them more happy unfulfilled this instead
it rocks it takes away their attention
so I believe the next big movement and
how we built technical systems will be
hygienic technology it will be how to
build systems that is careful with our
attention how they use it and that is
careful with our way of living and what
we want to achieve with the tools that
we are building
[Music]
you